[Music]
I'm gonna ask a question we can only
answer by saying either yes no or it's
complicated all right so let's start
over here is some form of super
intelligence possible yawn
just know where it's complicated yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes definitely
no this was disappointing we didn't find
any disagreements this is right harder
just because it's possible doesn't mean
it's actually going to happen so so
before I asked if super intelligence is
possible at all according to the laws of
physics now I'm asking will it actually
happened yes no or it's complicated
a little bit complicated but yes yes and
if it doesn't something terrible has
happened to prevent it yes probably yes
yes yes yes No
[Laughter]
shucks still haven't found any
interesting disagreements we need to try
try harder still okay so you think it is
gonna happen but would you actually like
it to happen at some point yes no or
it's called complicated leaning towards
yes it's complicated yes yes it's really
complicated yes it's complicated very
complicated there's not much kind all
right so it's getting a little bit more
interested when I think we had a really
faceted when is this can happen well we
had a really fascinating discussion
already in this morning's panel about
when we might get the human level AI so
that would sort of put a lower bound I
don't in the interest of time I I think
we don't need to rehash the question of
when and going beyond that might start
but but let's ask a very related
question to the one that just came up
here named evil the question of well if
something starts to happen if you get
some sort of recursive self-improvement
or some other process whereby
intelligence starting machine starts to
take off very very rapidly there's
always a timescale associated with this
and there I hope we can finally find
some real serious disagreements to argue
about here now some people have been
envisioning this scenario where it goes
Foom and things happen in days or hours
or or less whereas others envision that
will happen but it might take thousands
of years or decades so if you think of
some sort of doubling time or some sort
of rough time scale on which things get
dramatically better what times what time
with what timescale would you guess that
yawn
no no so once we get to human-level AI
and or whatever point beyond their or a
little bit before there where those of
youth where where things actually start
taking off
what is it sort of timescale any
explosion as a nerdy physicist has some
sort of time scale right on it happens
are we talking about seconds or years or
millennia I'm thinking of years but but
it's important to act as if this
timeline was shorter yeah I actually
don't really trust my intuitions here I
have intuitions that were thinking of
years but I also think human-level AI is
a mirage it's going to be suddenly
better than human but whether whether
that's going to be a full intelligence
explosion quickly I don't know depends
on the architecture that ends up
delivering human-level AI so kind of
neuroscience inspired by that way to
seem to be building the moment there
needs to be trained and have experience
and other things to gain knowledge there
may you know it may be on the order of a
few years so possibly even a decade some
numbers of years are but it could also
be much less but I would be surprised if
it was much more yeah
potentially days are shorter especially
if it's AI researchers designing AI
researchers every time there's in
advance in AI we dismiss it as oh well
that's not really AI chesco self-driving
cars and AI as you know it's the field
of things we haven't done yet that'll
continue when we actually reach AGI
there'll be lots of controversy by the
time the controversy settles down we'll
realize it it's been around for a few
years
yeah so it was related I think we will
go beyond human capabilities in many
different areas but not in all at the
same time so it will be an uneven
process with some areas you'll be far
advanced very soon already to some
extent and others might take much longer
what Bart said but I think if it reaches
the threshold where it says as far as
the smartest most inventive human then I
mean it really could be I mean a matter
of days before it's smarter than some of
humanity so here we saw it's quite an
interesting range of answers and this I
I I find it's a very interesting
question because for reasons that people
here have published a lot of interesting
papers about the time scale makes a huge
difference right if it's something it's
happening on the timescale of the
Industrial Revolution for example that's
a lots more longer than the time scale
on which society can adapt and take
measures to steer the development you
boring your nice rocket metaphor yawn
whereas if things happen much quicker
than then society can respond it's much
harder to steer and you kind of have to
hope that you've built in a good
steering in advance so in in for example
nuclear reactors we we nerdy physicists
like to stick graphite sticks and as
moderators to slow things down and maybe
even prevent it from going critical I'm
curious if any of one of you feels that
it would be nice if this growth of
intelligence which you're generally
excited about with some caveats if any
of you would like to have it happen a
bit slower and so it becomes easier for
society to keep shaping it the way we
want it and if so and here's the tough
question is there anything we could do
now or or later on when it when when it
gets closer that might make this
intelligence explosion or a rapid growth
and Tony's simply proceed slower so we
can have we can have more influence over
it does anyone want to take your swing
if this is not for a whole pound but
anyone reminded of the conversation we
had with Rick rich Sutton in Puerto Rico
like we had a lot of disagreements but
definitely we could agree about both
slow and BP better than Foster any any
thoughts about how we one could make it
a little bit slower well I mean the
strategy I suggested in my talk was
somewhat tongue-in-cheek but it was also
serious I I think this conference is
great and there's technologists we
should do everything we can to keep the
technology safe and beneficial and
certainly as we do each specific
applications like self-driving cars
there's a whole host of ethical issues
to address but I don't think we can
solve the problem just technologically
you imagine that we've done our job
perfectly and we've created you know the
most safe beneficial AI possible but
we've let the political system become
totalitarian and evil you know a world
evil world government or even just a
portion of the globe that that's at that
is that way it's not going to work out
well and so part of the struggle is in
the area of politics and social policy
to have the world reflect the values we
want to achieve because we're talking
about human AI human AI is by definition
at human levels and therefore is human
and so the issue of how do we make
humans ethical it's the same issue is
how we make a is that our human level
ethical yeah so what I'm hearing you say
is that before we reach the point of
beginning close to human level yeah a
very good way to prepare for that is for
us humans in our human society to try to
get our act together as much as possible
to have the world run with more reason
than then it perhaps is today is that
fair that's exactly what I'm saying
Nick oh so I just want to clarify again
that when I asked about slope what how
what you would do to slow things that
I'm not talking at all about slowing
down AI research now we're simply
talking about if we get to the point
that we're getting very near human-level
AI and think we might get some very fast
development how could one slow that part
down so one yeah it would be to make
faster progress now so you get to that
point sooner when hardware is less
developed you get less Hardware overhang
however the current speed of AI progress
is a fairly hard variable to change very
much because there are big forces
pushing on it so perhaps the high
the city option is what I suggested in
the talk to ensure that whoever gets
there first has enough of a lead that
they're able to slow down for a few
months let us say to go slow during the
transition I think one one thing you can
do I mean this is almost in the
verification area is is to make systems
that provably will not recruit
additional hardware or redesign their
hardware so that their resources remain
fixed and I'm quite happy to sit there
for for several years thinking hard
about what the next step would be to
take enough trivial to copy software
software is self-replicating and always
has been and that I don't see how you
can possibly stop that I mean I think it
would be great if it went slow but it's
very hard to see how it does go slow
given the huge first mover advantages in
getting to super intelligence so the
only scenario I see where it might go
slow is where there's only one potential
first mover that can then stop and think
so yeah maybe that speaks to creating a
creating a society where you know AI is
restricted and unified but without
multiple movies yeah them as so so
you're calling Shane leg mentioned that
one one thing that could help a lot here
is if there's things like this industry
partnership and a sense of trust and
openness between the leaders so that if
there is a point where I want there yeah
I do worry about you know that scenario
where you know I think I've got you know
quite high belief in the in you know in
human ingenuity to solve these problems
given enough time the control problems
and other issues they're very difficult
but I think we can solve them the
problem is is will there you know the
coordination problem of making sure
there is enough time to slow down at the
end and you know let's do it think about
this for five years but what about you
know he may do that but what about all
the other teams that are reading the
papers and are not gonna do that while
you're thinking you know this is the
this is what I worry about quite a lot
because it seems like that coordination
problem is quite difficult but I think
it's a first step may be coordinating
you know things like partnership in on
AI you know the most capable teams
together at least agree on a set of
protocols or safety procedures or things
you know agree that maybe you know we
should verify these systems and that is
gonna take three years and we should
think about that I think that would be a
good thing I just want to carry out one
thing about
slowing and versus fast progresses you
know it could be that imagine there was
a moratorium on AI research fifty years
but Hardware continue to accelerate as
it does now we could write you know it's
a sort of what Nick's point was is that
it could be a massive cover of hammer
something we're then AI actually many
many many different approaches to AI
including seed AI self-improving I all
these things could be possible and you
know maybe if one person their garage
can do it and I think now be a lot more
difficult to coordinate that kind of
secure were so I think there's some are
going to be made where you want to make
fast progress when we're at the very
hard point of the s-curve were actually
you know you need quite a large team
that'll be quite visible you know who
the other people are and you know in a
sense society can keep tabs on who the
who the major players are and and what
they're up to we know we're supposed to
a scenario where it's a 50 100 years
time when you know someone a kid in
their in their garage could create a C
dengle something yeah Bart one last
comment so since I think that this
process will be a very irregular process
and sometimes we will be far advanced in
our times will be quite quite going
quite slow yeah I'm sort of hoping that
when society sees something like fake
video creation or quite a video way if
somebody say made-up things and and that
society will actually realize that are
and these new capabilities for the
machines and and we should start taking
the problem as a society more seriously
before we have foulon generally I well
years AI to detect that so you you
mentioned some words the word worry
there and an eunuch went a bit farther
you had the word doom written on your
slides three times no wonder there was
one star on Amazon and there and that it
was even in a red color and I think it's
just as important to talk about
existential hope and the fantastic
upside as downside and I want to do a
lot of that here but so let's just get
some of the some of those worries out of
the way
now and then return to the positive
things so well just want to go through
it quickly and give each one of you a
chance just pick
one thing that you feel it's a challenge
that we should overcome in and then say
something about what you feel is the
best thing we can do right now to try to
mitigate it
you want to start young to me to get
what to try mention one thing that
you're worried could go wrong and tell
us about something constructive that we
can do now that will reduce that risk oh
I I do think that they I ounce racers I
see like a lot of good I'm really
heartened to see you know great contacts
between open AI and deep mind but I
think this is just like a sort of toy
model of what the world at large might
come up with in terms of arms races and
I mean myself I've been spending
actually increasing amounts of time in
Asia recently just they're going to try
to kind of pull in more people elsewhere
what has been so far is just being kind
of like a anglo-american discussion
mostly so like this is I think this is
one thing that that should be done and
I'm gonna do it someone who's outside
this field I think the challenge I'm
really in touch with is how hard it is
to take the safety concerns emotionally
seriously and I add how hard it is for
people in the field to do that as well I
can't tell you how many people outside
this room who purport to be experts
think the control problem is a total
non-issue it's just it's flabbergasting
to meet these people and just and
therefore not worth thinking about and
one of the reasons i think is that in
the one case there's there's this
illusion that that the time horizon
matters if you feel that this is 50 or
100 years away
that is totally consoling but there's an
implicit assumption there the the
assumption is that you know how long it
will take to build this safely and that
50 or a hundred years is enough time the
other issue is I think most people feel
like intelligence is an intrinsic good
and
of course we want more of it and and
it's very easy to be in touch with that
assumption because right now there's a
cure for cancer which we have not
discovered right at how galling is that
and but for more intelligence but but
for knowing which experiments to run or
how to integrate the data we already
have in hand we would we would have a a
cure for cancer that was actionable now
unless there was some physical law of
the universe that prevented us from
curing cancer which seems unlikely so it
the the pain of not having enough
intelligence is is really excruciating
when you when you focus on it but and I
think to your previous question of doing
this quickly becomes an intrinsic good
provided we have solved the alignment
problems and the political problems and
the chaos that would that would follow
if we were just if we did it
quickly without solving those problems
so I think it's the the thing that is
alarming is how ethereal these concerns
are even to those who have no rational
argument against them so some it's it
sounds to me like you're agreeing very
strongly what Shayne legs said that
there is in some circles are still the
strong taboo that you know don't even
think consider the possibility that we
might get AGI because it's just
absolutely ridiculous and he was arguing
that the sooner we can get rid of this
Tabo the the sooner people can get to
work and find all these really helpful
solutions and answers that we need so
suppose for a moment that I came up to
you and I said to you this idea of
superhuman intelligence sounds
absolutely ridiculous it sounds
completely nuts and by the way I've
never seen your TED talk you know and
we're in an elevator you have only 30
seconds to persuade me to take this more
seriously but would you say and well a
lot of people who are here will have
this exact conversation with colleagues
and others and what well there there are
very few assumptions you need to make to
take this seriously intellectually again
the emotional part is a separate piece
but
if you assume that intelligence is just
on some level the product of information
processing in a physical system and
there are very few people who dispute
that in who are scientifically
illiterate at this point and you assume
that we will continue to improve our
information processing systems unless
something terrible happens to us to
prevent that and that seems like a very
safe assumption then it is just a matter
of time before we instantiate something
that is human level and beyond in in our
computers and again the time horizon is
only consoling on the assumption that we
know we have enough time to solve the
alignment problems and the political
problems that we examine the other thing
is it's humbling here that Ray brought
up at one point that even if we were
handed a perfectly been benign well
behaved AI just from God you know we're
given a perfect Oracle we're given a
perfect inventor of of good technology
given our current political and economic
atmosphere we would that would produce
total chaos we just have not we don't
have the the the ethical or political
will to share the wealth we don't have
the the political integration to deal
with the you know the this thing being
given to Silicon Valley and not being
given at the same moment to China or
Iran so there's just it's it's it's
alarming that the best case scenario
currently you know basically just
ripping out 80% of Nyx book because
we've solved all those problems is still
a terrifying one and they're so clearly
that's a near-term thing that we have to
solve thank you so Dennis you want to
tell us about one thing that you feel is
its challenge and and and say something
about what we should focus on now yeah I
think I could I think it's you know I
agree with with both statements already
said that so I think the coordination
problem is one thing where you know we
want to we want to avoid this sort of
harmful race to the finish where you
know corner-cutting starts happening and
things like safety easy things to you
know will get whether things will get
cut but
cause obviously they don't necessarily
directly contribute to AI capability
fact they may hold it back a bit by
making a safe AI so I think that's
that's going to be a big issue on a
global scale and it seems like I know
that's going to be a hard problem when
we're talking about national governments
and things and I think also you know we
haven't thought enough about the whole
governance scenario of how do we want
you know those a is to be out in the
world how many of them and how they know
who will set their goals all these kinds
of things I think needs a lot more
thought you know once we've already
solved the technical problems I think
it's wonderful that you're not just
saying these things but actually doing
these things and she played a leading
role in setting up the partnership on AI
here which goes exactly in the direction
of what you're advocating is you want to
pass it off off to make sure there's
nothing at all you're worried about
right so tell us about one concrete
useful thing you would like to see on
that I mean so it's a fun technical work
bringing top talents to work on these
technical issues build these
collaborations build a community build
trust works or more on figuring out
attractive solutions to the government
solutions that could work but don't rush
to implement the first idea have it
first the trial them out a little bit
more so yeah I I think a lot about
consciousness so I was really struck by
the the sentience caution I'm a list of
principles here that said avoid overly a
vote avoid strong assumptions about the
distribution of consciousness in the
eyes which I take it entails avoid
assuming that any human level or
superhuman level AGI is going to be
conscious for me that raises the
possibility of a massive failure mode in
the in the future the possibility that
we create human or superhuman level AGI
and we've got a world populated by to be
human level Agis
none of whom is conscious and that would
be a world could potentially be a world
of great intelligence no consciousness
no subjective experience at all now it
took many many people and for wide
variety of views take the view the
basically subjective experience or
consciousness is required in order to
have any meaning or value in your life
at all so therefore a world without
consciousness could not possibly be a
positive i'll
maybe wouldn't be a terribly negative
outcome it would just be a zero health
common among the worst possible outcome
so I worry about avoiding that outcome
as a matter of fact I'm fairly
optimistic about the possibilities that
AI is the various kinds will be
conscious but insofar as this community
is making that assumption I think it's
then it's important to actually think
about the question of in creating AGR's
are we actually creating conscious
beings only one thing that we ought to
at least consider doing there is making
given that we don't understand
consciousness we don't have a complete
theory of consciousness maybe we can be
most confident about consciousness when
that's similar to the cases the case we
know about the best namely human so what
are human consciousness so therefore
there's may be an imperative to create
human like AGI in order that we can be
maximally confident that there's gonna
be consciousness so what I hear you say
is it is that when you have a nightmare
about the zombie or cop apocalypse
you're not thinking about some silly
Terminator movie but you're thinking
about this problem we create we upload
ourselves do all these wonderful things
but there's no one home is that fair to
say I mean this is a different kind of
existential risk one kind of existential
risk is there's no humans there's
there's a is some people might say well
that's okay there are there are services
I'm much worse existential risk is there
is not there are no conscious beings in
our future so make a confession so Shane
leg mentioned that there's been the
strong taboo about talking about the
possibility of intelligence getting very
advanced it's clearly also been a strong
taboo for a long time to mention the
c-word in fact before the conference
when we got all these responses on the
first round of the principles yes which
one was ranked last hmm got huge amounts
of - one ratings that was the one with
consciousness we changed that the stated
and stated it better and then it got
stated is still better at lunch and it's
still rated last so that's why even
though even though I personally share
your interests in this a lot of the 8%
of people agreed yeah sentience quotient
but not 90 so that one also fell off the
list yeah so maybe that's another taboo
you can personally help bus shadows so
people think for that question or Ray
anything else you're concerned about and
any stress on what I was going to say
but just who was
a converse concern is we create a GIS
everybody assumes that of course it's
just a machine and therefore it's not
conscious but actually it is suffering
but we don't look out for its conscious
subjective experience because we are
making the wrong assumption but what I
did want to say was the three
overlapping revolutions people to talk
about GN are genetics biotech
nanotechnology in robotics which is AI
and their bit there are proposals there
was the CLM our conferences done here
decades ago for biotech that have worked
fairly well there are similar proposals
for nanotechnology there's a difference
with AI and that there really isn't a
foolproof technical solution to this you
can have technical controls on say
nanotechnology one of the guidelines is
it shouldn't be self-replicating it's
not really realistic because it can't
scale to meaningful quantities without
being self-replicating but you can
imagine technical protections if you
have an AI that's more intelligent than
you and it's out for your destruction or
it's out for the world's destruction and
there's no other AI but superior to it
that's a bad situation so that that's
the specter and partly this is amplified
by our observation of what we as humans
the most intelligent species on the
planet have done to other species if we
look at how we treat animals people you
know are very free like their dogs and
and pets but if you look at factory
farming were not very benign to species
that are less intelligent than us that
that engenders a lot of the concern we
see that if there's a new ant type of
entity that's more intelligent than us
it's kind of treat us like we have
treated other species so that's the
concern that you know I do think what
we're doing at this conference is
appropriate I I wanted to mention that
I think we should publish these
guidelines the way the Asilomar
guidelines and biotech were published
decades ago and then people can and
people can you can have an opt-in
opt-out but I think we should actually
say we had this conference and the a Ike
leadership community you know has come
up with these guidelines and people can
respond to them and debate them and then
maybe the next conference will provide
some you sell them our biotech
guidelines have been revised many times
but I would advocate we actually take a
stand and put forth of these guidelines
and then let the whole community at
large debate them and have them be have
them guide our research it's actually
worked quite well in biotech alright
okay yeah so let me give a little
different perspective so so one concern
I have at a high level is these machines
become really smart or even in certain
areas can humans still understand what
the decisions they did that they
suggested that they make and I work in
infill ultimate reasoning where we have
you know significant advanced last two
decades going from bones there's a few
hundred variables to promise of millions
of variables being soft not quite
routinely and there was a sense in the
community well you know there be getting
answers from these from his reasoning
engines mostly hardware software
application problems but we can not
humans can no longer understand these
answers and last few years people have
actually discovered that you you can use
the machine to generate explanations for
their answers that are again human
understandable so I see sort of a
glimmer of hope that maybe even if we
have lost much less intelligence we may
be able to understand solutions that
machine's find for us and we could not
find these solutions but they may be
able to provide explanations that are
accessible to us so that's a little
positive note Thank You Stuart
so there are two things that keep me
awake at night other than email
so one is the problem of misuse and bad
actors you know to take an analogy it's
it's as if we were building nuclear
weapons and then delivering them by
email to everybody on the planet saying
here's a toy you know do what you want
how do we counter that just hey I don't
really have a good solution I think one
of the things we have to do is to make
to make designs for safe AI very clear
and simple and sort of make it
unthinkable to do anything other than
that right just like it's unthinkable to
have a program with an infinite loop
that produces a spinning pizza of death
on your oh sorry
what's unthinkable to have a buffer
overflow that allows your your software
to be hacked into the other thing that
keeps me awake is actually the the
possibility that success would lead to
you know sort of AI as a helicopter
parent for the human race that would
sort of ossify and gradually enfeeble us
so and they would but there'll be no
point of which it was obvious to us that
this was happening and I think the
mitigation which you asked for to look
on the bright side is that in some sense
the the the meta value of human evolved
ability right the free the freedom to
change the future is something that the
AI needs to adopt and in some sense that
would result eventually in the AI
receding into the background and saying
okay now you know I've got you through
your adolescence now it's time for the
human race to grow up now that we have
the capabilities to eliminate scarcity
to eliminate needless conflict and and
coordination failures and and all those
things that we suffer from right now so
I could imagine a distant future where
in fact AI is perhaps even less visible
than it is today
great finally yeah you Ilan as far as I
know never ever expressed any concerns
about AI right I'm just wondering if
very fine
if there is any ya child and concerns
you in particular any concerns that you
see there's a very clear thing we should
be doing now that that are gonna help
well I mean try to think of like you
know what what what is an actual good
future what does that actually look like
or at least battle and how you would
characterize it because it to the point
that was made only I think made about me
of my salmon and my list that we're
headed towards ether superintelligence
or civilization ending those are those
like the two things that are like that
that will happen it intelligence will
keep advancing nothing they would
advancing is something that what's
solution into stasis or destroy a
civilization so then we forgot what is a
world that would we would like to be in
where there is this digital super
intelligence I think the and another
point that I think is really important
to appreciate is that we are all of us
already are sidewalks so you have a
machine extension of yourself in the
form of your your phone and your
computer and all your applications you
are already superhuman but by far you
have a more powerful capability then
surprising the United States had you
know thirty years ago if you have an
internet link you have an article of
wisdom you can communicate to millions
of people you communicate to the rest of
Earth instantly and these are magical
powers that didn't exist not that long
ago so everyone is already superhuman
and a sidewalk the limitation is one of
bandwidth so we're bandwidth constrained
particularly on output so our input is
much better but our output is extremely
slow now if you want to be generous you
could say maybe it's a few hundred bits
per second or a kilobyte or something
like that
output a bit you know the way we we are
put is likely about little meat sticks
that we move spray slowly and and push
buttons or tap tap a little screen and
and that's just extremely slow and you
know compared to a computer which can
communicate at the terabyte level it's a
very big orders many two differences the
our input is much better because of
vision but even that could be enhanced
significantly I think I think the the
the two things that are needed for look
for a good future that we would look at
and concluded is good most likely is we
we have to solve that bandwidth
constraint with it with a direct neural
interface I think a high bandwidth
interface to the cortex so that we can
have a digital tertiary layer that's
more full of more fully symbiotic with
with the rest of us like we've got we've
got the cortex and the limbic system
which seems to work together pretty well
they've got good bandwidth whereas the
bandwidth to a digital toshi layer is is
weak so I think if we can solve that
bandwidth issue and then AI can be
widely available yeah add the analogy to
nuclear bomb is not exactly correct it's
it's not it's not as though it's gonna
explode and create a mushroom cloud it's
more like if if there were just a few
people that had it that they would be
able to be essentially addicted
dictators of Earth or you know whoever
acquired it and and and if it was
limited to us one of the people there
and it was ultra smart they what they
would have dominion over earth so I
think it's extremely important that it
be widespread and that we solve the
bandwidth issue and if we do those
things then then it will be tied to our
consciousness tied to our will tied to
the sum of individual human will and and
everyone would habits so we sort of
stole a relatively even playing field in
fact it would
probably more egalitarian than today
great thank you so much that's in fact
the perfect segue into the last question
I want to ask you before we open it up
to everybody something I really missed
in the discussion about really advanced
intelligence beyond human is more
thoughts about the upside we have so
much talk about existential risk and not
just in the academic context but just
flip on your TV
check out Netflix what do you see there
in in these scientific visions of the
future is almost always dystopia is
right
for some reason fear gives more clicks
than the positive visions but if I have
a student coming into my office at MIT
asking for career advice the first thing
I'm gonna ask is ask her as you know
howdy
where will you want to be in 20 years
and if she does says well maybe I'll get
cancer maybe I'll get run over by a bus
you know that's a terrible way to think
about here we are planning ready I want
her to be on fire and say you know my
vision is I want to do this and here are
the things that could go wrong and then
you can plan out how to avoid those
problems and get it I would love to see
more discussion about the upsides a
futures we're really excited about so we
can not just run avoid problems for the
sake of avoiding problems but to get to
something that we're all really on fire
about so to start off I'll just tell you
something that makes me really excited
about advanced artificial intelligence
everything I love but civilization is
the product of intelligence the if we
for some reason word is that well you
know I'm scared about this technology
thing
let's just press pause on it forever
there's no interesting question about if
we're gonna have human extinction
question is just when you know is it
going to be a supervolcano is it gonna
be the next dinosaur class killing class
asteroid you know the last one happened
60 million years ago so how long is it
going to be pretty horrible whew
just sit in wonder one that when when
we're gonna get taken out here without
the technology when we know that we
totally have the brainpower to solve all
these problems if we if we proceed
forward and develop technology so just
that was just them my one thing that
makes me very excited about moving
forward rather than pressing pause I
want to just ask the same question to
all of you guys in turn so tell us just
pretty briefly about something that you
are really excited about some future
vision you imagine with with very dry
and start villages that you're really
excited about that you would like to see
yawn so I want to be careful when I
imagine concrete fruit of of HD I like
on a meta level I think sort of as a
first approximation I think we should
just maximize the amount of fun and
minimize the amount of suffering
I think Eliezer has written a sequence
called
fun theory where he points out that
people have been horrible imagining and
very unimaginative imagining paradises
of various sorts that just like really
boring places actually when you think
about them
I think eighties art has this sketch
whereas I'd like it what's hard to spend
like one week and meet my relatives like
imagine spending like eternity with a
dead relative but yeah so I think we
should be concerned about side effects
and try to capture dynamics of
improvement and basically go from there
make sure that we're gonna adjust the
trajectory as we get smarter and and
more grown together great thinking
you're on Sam
what do you get excited about well
strangely the what excites me is just
really just a butts the the parts that
scare me the most I think what is nice
about this conversation in particular
about the alignment problem is that it's
forcing us to realize that there are
better and worse answers to questions of
human value and someone said perhaps at
this last meeting in Puerto Rico that we
have
we really have to do philosophy on a
deadline and we have to have to admit to
ourselves that there are better and
worse answers and we have to converge on
the better ones and what would excite me
about actually the birth of super
intelligent AI one of the things apart
from solving obvious problems like
curing disease and energy issues and all
the rest but is perhaps differs a little
bit with what Stuart said I am not so
worried about idiocracy or all of us
just losing our way as Apes and living
unproductive lives in dialog with these
these Oracle's I think actually I would
want a truly value aligned super
intelligence to incrementally show us
not not not merely conserve what we want
but show us what we should want to get
to keep improving our values so that we
can we can navigate in the space of all
possible experiences and converge on on
better and better ones thank you Sam
what about you Dennis so I mean
obviously this is why I spent my whole
career working on this is that if I
think if we do this right it's going to
be the greatest thing ever to happen to
reality and in some ways I think unlock
our full potential I mean I've talked a
lot about and all my talks about using
it as a tool to help us make science and
medical breakthroughs faster that sort
of even as an obvious one but so we're
taking that longer term one reason I got
so into AI is that like probably many of
you in this room you know I'm
interesting the biggest questions of why
we're here understanding our minds what
is consciousness what's the nature of
the universe what's our purpose and if
we're going to try and really grapple
any of those questions I think we're
going to need something like AI perhaps
with ourselves enhanced as well too and
I think you know in that future world
will have a chance to actually find out
about some of these really deep
questions you know in the same way we're
finding out with alphago just about go
but what if we could do that with all of
science and physics and and and you know
the biggest questions in the universe
and I think you know that's going to be
the most exhilarating journey of all to
find that out you know to kiss carry
that on a few other things that people
commented on is you know in terms of
like
you know us as the most intelligent
beings on the planet right now and
treating animals badly and these sort of
things I think if you think about it
though you know let's take you know I
don't know tigers or something in India
they have huge Rangers and those people
very poor and they they they're a
resource poor but if they had abundant
resources I don't think they're
intentionally trying to kill off these
Tigers or I mean some cases they are but
often it's just because they need the
land for their cattle and and that's
this the tiger needs you know whatever a
number of kilometers where kilometers to
live one tiger and it's just difficult
with a number of people that are there
so I think if we solve the kind of
abundance and scarcity problem then I
think that opens up our you know I think
a lot of conflicts both you know between
humans as well as to do with reason or
scarcity but at the heart of it so I see
you know if we can solve a lot of these
problems I can see a much better future
okay
so Nick you you pointed out that there
would the upside part of your book was a
little bit shorter so that I have a
chance to add something positive what
are you excited about they're really two
sites that's one is getting rid of a lot
of the negatives that like the
compassionate use to cure diseases and
all other kinds of horrible miseries
that exist on the planet today so that
is a large chunk of the potential but
then beyond that if foreign really wants
to see realistically what the positive
things are that could be developed I
think one has to think outside the
constraints of our current human
biological nature that it's unrealistic
to imagine a trajectory stretching
hundreds of thousands of years into the
future we have super intelligence we
have material abundance and yet we are
still these bipedal organisms with three
pounds of gray TCC matter with a fixed
set of emotional sensitivities and the
hedonic set point that is kind of
okayish for most people but if you get
you know something really good happens
it lasts a short time and then you're
back to the baseline I think all of
these basic parameters that sort of
define the human game today
I mean become up for grabs in this
future and it opens up this much
vascular space of posthuman modes of
beings some of which I think could be
wonderful literally beyond our ability
to imagine in terms of the
mental states types of activities to
understanding the ways of relating so I
don't think we need a detailed blueprint
for utopia now what we need is to get
ourselves in the position later on where
we can have the ability to use this to
realize the values that come into view
once we take steps forward Thank You Nik
what about you David I'm excited about
the possibilities for AI making us
humans smarter I mean some of it is
selfish I turned 50 last year my brain
is gradually becoming slower and older
and and dumber but not sure that I am
and that's partly because you know well
the augmented intelligence technology
we're using you know smartphones and the
internet and so on are giving me all
kinds of capacities extended capacities
that I didn't have before and I'm really
looking forward to AI helping with uh
with that you know in ten years or so
once everyone is wearing augmented
reality glasses with deep learning built
into it and I'm really gonna I'm really
gonna need that around around sixty and
if you guys really get on the case and
by you know by the time I'm 70 or so
we've got you know yeah
real genuine AI or AI modules out there
which could somehow come to be
integrated with my my my brain processes
or maybe eventually we get to upload our
entire brains onto AI then there's a
there's a way potentially to get you
know smarter more intelligent forever
this is not just selfish although you
have it I can't say that doesn't
motivate me but yeah demos talked about
the AI scientist I also like to think
about the AI philosopher you know the
problems our philosophy really hard and
many people have speculated that we
humans are just too dumb to solve the
solve some of them but once we've
actually got a is on the scene maybe AI
enhanced humans and maybe we're gonna be
able to cross those across those
thresholds where where the AI enhance
human thought maybe just the AG guys end
up solving some of those problems the
philosophy for once and for all
great ray you have been a true pioneer
and articulating positive vision of the
future in your writing so if you would
pick the one that you're most excited
about now what would that be imagine
going back 10,000 years and ask
a quintessential caveman and woman he
what what is a beneficial future what
would you like to see and they would say
well it's like this fire to stop going
out and like a bigger bolder to prevent
the animals from getting in the cave
anything else well no I think that would
be pretty perfect
don't you want a better website and apps
and search engines and imagine going
back two million years ago and talking
to primates if you could do that and
saying isn't it great the frontal cortex
is coming and you have additional
neocortex and higher hierarchy and they
say well what's the point of that and
said well you'll have music and and
humor and the answer would be
what's music what's what's humor so they
couldn't imagine concepts that they
couldn't imagine and by analogy I think
we will have new phenomena that are as
profound as music in humor it could call
it more profound music and and will be
funnier but I think it'll be as profound
as these great leaps that evolution has
brought us because we will become
profoundly smarter and you know if music
and humor are up here and we go to even
higher levels of the neocortex we're
going to have more profound ways of
expressing ourselves once we have that
we would not want to go back what about
you Bart well I pretty much agrees that
we we can't really predict much in
advance what what we would like to have
for myself personally I see the
developments in mathematics and
discovering and then some ease and
discovery and computers are just the
hybrids of human computers they are it's
quite incredible and makes the fuels
make sure we do much more exciting so I
think that will be in the near future
the first thing great and what about you
Stuart well so like Jeffery Sachs I
think that for many of us and or we like
the cavemen
that for many of us life is pretty
amazing and for many more of us it isn't
and I think the the best thing that I
can do the big upside is actually to to
fix the latter problem I mean I I love
Nick's feeling that there are higher
states of being that that are so far
above our current pretty good that that
that balance is out all the the pretty
bad that a lot of people are suffering
but I I really think the the emphasis
should be on the pretty bad and fixing
it and eliminating so demos was reading
my notes apparently across the room but
eliminating the scarcity basically
eliminates the need for people to act in
a zero-sum fashion where they can only
get by by making it less possible for
someone else to get by and I think
that's the source of a lot of the the
nastiness that jeffrey mentioned earlier
so I think that would be my my main
upside and not having to read so much
email for you Elan
you've never articulated an e o any
visionary ideas about the future as far
as I know either what about now I think
I just yeah I haven't have thought about
this a lot and I think it just really
just comes down to two things and it's
it's the solving the the Machine brain
bandwidth constraint and democratization
of AI I think we have those two things
the future will be good was a great
quote by Lord Acton which is that you
know freedom consists of the district
distribution of power and despotism in
its concentration and I think as long as
we have as long as long as AI powers
like anyone can get it if they want it
and you know we've got something faster
than meat sticks to communicate with
then I think the future will be good
fantastic
B so let's get in I know your caffeine
levels are dropping
dangerously low and we also have another
panel after this which is gonna be
really exciting to listen to so let's do
it it's just a few quick questions make
sure that they are actually questions
and say your name and also say pick one
person on the panel and address it just
to them okay
Joshua Joshua Benjamin trio and it's for
young I've found your your your
presentation very inspiring and one
question I have is related to the
question of list stating preference and
values from from people do you think
this this line of investigation could
lead to better democracy better society
more direct democracy and you know what
do you think about this direction to
deal with the issue of misuse and things
like that yes absolutely like one code
name for this even could be like
democracy 2.0 or uun 2.0 or something
like that so and as I mentioned in my
presentation like just I mean a lot of
people today basically want to make the
world better but it's kind of hard to
distinguish them from people who say
they want to make the world better so if
there was actually kind of like a very
easy measuring like a metric that that
basically would work as a selling point
focal point then I think that would be
super helpful and and yeah like
democracy was invented like hundreds of
years ago so so and clearly we have
advanced as a civilization and we have
better knowledge about how to aggregate
aggregate preferences and Nicolas
Berggruen over there thank you max
Nicolas Berggruen so have a very almost
naive question this is a very
well-meaning group in terms of its
intentions that who who sort of looking
at who else is doing potentially AGI it
could be well beyond this group it could
be in China could be anyplace
what happens because we've talked about
how powerful AGI is and if Iran is
correct if it's distributed fairly fine
but if it isn't is there a way to
monitor today on a year and 10 years
because once it's out it'll be fast who
is monitoring it who who has a tab on it
because this is self selected but beyond
Ilan or dumbest is either one of you
want to take a swing at this well I
think this is sort of relates to my
point I said earlier about trying to
build AI at the hard part of the S curve
so which i think is where we sort of are
at the moment as far as we can tell
because you know it's not easy to make
this kind of progress so you need you
need quite a lot of people they're quite
smart and that community is pretty small
still even though it's getting rapidly
bigger at places like nips and so and
most people know each other so this is
pretty representative of everyone in the
West at least obviously that's harder to
know what's happening in China or in in
in Russia maybe but you know I think
that you need quite a large footprint of
resources you know people and very smart
people and lots of compute and so on so
I think that narrows down the scope of
the number of groups who can do that and
it also means that they're more visible
so you know I think certainly in the
West I think most people on here someone
in these in this room will have contact
with somebody who's in those groups who
are capable of you know making
meaningful progress towards AGI it's
harder to know in in in the east and and
further apart but we should try and make
links to those you know national Chinese
National Academy of Sciences and so on
to find out more but you know that may
change in the future that's the current
state it's the bad news is it's getting
late in the day and we only have time
for one more question
the good news is there's a coffee break
right after this so you can ask all your
questions if you swarm the panel and the
last question is goes to you Eric you
want to stand up Eric green Olson MIT
I'm gonna pick up on the thing that Ilan
said at the end about
democratizing the the coming tide back
to the panel yesterday where we're Reed
Hoffman talked about people carrying a
lot about not just absolute income but
relative income and wanted to get the
the panelists reactions to the thoughts
about whether or not AI had tendencies
towards a winner-take-all effects that
there's a tendency for its concentration
that whoever's ahead can pull further
ahead or whether there's potential for
more widespread Democratic access to it
or in what kinds of mechanisms we can
put in place if we want to have the
widely shared prosperity that you once
adjusted along do you want to take that
yeah well I mean I have to say that
we're doing something is the danger to
the public then the there needs to be
some I hate safe government agency like
regulators like I'm not the biggest fan
of regulators like it's a bit of a
buzzkill
you know but I if the fact is like we've
got regulators in you know the aircraft
industry car industry deal with them all
time drugs food you know and anything
that's sort of a public risk and I think
this has to fall into the category of a
public risk and you know I think that
like this or anything to and I think it
will happen questions with a the
government reaction speed matches the
advancement speed of AI governments
react slowly and got us move slowly and
they tend to be reactive as opposed to
proactive and but you can look at these
other industries and say like does
anybody really want the FAA to go away
you know it's like there's to be a
free-for-all for aircraft like probably
not you know if like there's reason is
there or just people just give any kind
of drugs and you know maybe they work
maybe they don't and we have that in
supplements like it was kind of
ridiculous but I think on balance FDA is
good so I think I think we probably need
some kind of
regulatory authority and I think it's
like the rebuttal to that is like well
people just like move to friggin Costa
Rica or something that's not true okay
like we don't see Boeing moving to Costa
Rica or to you know Venezuela or
wherever it's like free and loose the to
Demeter's point the the AI is
overwhelmingly likely to be developed
where there is a concentration of AI
research talent and that happens to be
in a few places in the world you know
it's Silicon Valley London in a Boston
if you sort of you up a few other places
but it's really just like a few places
that really regulators could have
reasonably access I don't want to be
clear it's not because I love regulators
okay from their name the neck but
they're necessary if to preserve the
public good at times all right on that
note let's thank the panel for a
fascinating discussion
[Music]